is there advice
you would give to a young person today
that looks up to the stars and wonders
what the heck they want to do with their
life
so career science life in general
you've uh for now chosen a certain kind
of path of curiosity
what uh what insights do you draw from
that that you can give us advice to
others
i think for somebody i i would not
presume to speak
to giving people advice on on life and
humanity overall but for somebody
thinking of
being a scientist so there are a couple
of things
one sort of practical thing which is
career-wise i hadn't appreciated this
going into science but
you need to so
the the questions you're working on and
the techniques you use
are both of very high importance maybe
equal importance for being happy in your
career
um if there are questions you're
interested in but the techniques that
you need to use to do them
are tedious for you then your job is
going to be miserable even if the
questions are inspiring
so you have to find but if the
techniques that you use are things that
excite you
then your job is fun every day so for me
i'm fascinated by the solar system and i
love
telescopes and i love doing data
analysis playing with data from
telescopes coming up with new ways to
use telescopes and so that's where i
have found that
mesh but if i was interested in you know
the dynamical evolution of the solar
system how the orbits of things evolve
then i would need to do
a different type of work that i would
just not find as appealing and so it
just wouldn't be a good fit and so
it sort of is seems like an unromantic
thing to have to think about the
techniques being the thing you want to
work on also but it really makes
a profound difference for i think your
happiness and your
scientific career i think that's really
profound it's like the thing
the menial tasks if you enjoy those
that's a really good sign that
that's the right path for you i think
david foster wallace said that
uh the key to life is to be unborrowable
so basically everything should be
exciting
i don't think that's feasible but you
should find an area where
everything is exciting i mean depending
on the day but you can
find the joy in everything not just the
big exciting
chronicle things that everyone thinks is
exciting but the
the details the the repetitive stuff the
meaning of the stuff that takes years
this
stuff that involves a lot of failure and
all those kinds of things that you find
that enjoyable that's that's actually
really profound to focus on that
uh because people talk about like dreams
and passion and goals and so on the big
thing
but that's not actually what takes you
there it takes you there's every single
day
putting in the hours and that's what
actually makes up life
is the boring bits if the boring bits
aren't boring
then that's an exciting life
you